alright next game here you have got an
Enzo I now transpose some maybe to the
samish variation which is some bit risky
from White's point of view but leads to
interesting play yeah 98 was play to
avoid the Bishop g5 pin now black so
this is some around move usually black
plays f5 to prevent exactly this here
not sure maybe this one putting pressure
on e6 yeah I always have to reckon with
with losing an opponent of course the
c-4 pond but I wonder about about about
d5 here if you place 'if I've the 96
okay it took maybe wants to play 96 now
yeah okay okay so I lost the pond which
is a very often happening in the same
question is do I get something against
the king I have my doubts that this is a
good position for me all right okay if
you play this opening you pretty much
know beforehand that it's a risky
business okay prevent some look f3
Brooke f3h three would have been would
have been an idea so what now
m-chuck this isn't really a good
position he can play 96 and Queen to e8
and pretty much defense I could go 96
anyway maybe I should even ok come on
it's just an exchange I think oh he
didn't take it this is surprising
should be starting to get a bit more
optimistic now we take the take with the
pawn and have those Queen h7 h eight
threads so I'll get the material back
but this helped me really in developing
pieces right these things I need to can
either look on the third-ranked it would
be absolutely great to have one rook f3
yeah I know it can take but I just love
to thread critics h7 with with me to
come Taylor announcement maybe I can
even I can even play this I'm not sure
take take if he takes on materia take
with the pollen g6 can it's it's a weird
position this night has no moves I can
try this and also I have the screen
takes h7 thread which is which is funny
came so now i'm i'm i'm an exchange down
and he cannot take he can but it's not
it's not clear that it really helps them
did this night is this is not doing so
I'm not doing anything it can go to c7
all right yeah Queen um he wants to use
the Queen on c5 yeah Bishop e3 looks
like a terribly slow move maybe rookie
one idea 97 lat yeah I am McKnight 97
roop takes rook takes Queen absent I
threat his covering from the fire yeah
okay very very questionable yeah maybe I
should have played Bishop e3 after all
it's not totally clear still but yeah
this should be good for black
queen bee 597 booked a group text I'm
not threatening anything okay returns
AHA to get the square we're still the
night cannot move maybe I can get in
this this funny Queen h7 after all ok
now I'm threatening it again
check i get i get to play this ah oh
that's funny black resigns yeah okay
don't try this at home looks likely this
was wasn't entirely corrected tech well
it was fun fun yeah this Queen c7 is is
just completely weird move from not not
quite sure I can I can I think you can
just take on d5 wow this is cool I just
I just started the computer and it gifts
it gives this computer position as equal
Queen a 397 check King f8 96 and it's
equal this is cool what a night what on
Queen d5 I let let me check this kingi
to UM Queen define what happened one
Queen D Phi he is also equal cool Jake's
takes yeah I thought it would be
difficult for him to make any progress
but I'm two points down but the night on
on on the 8th cannot move g6 he cannot
play because H 7s hanging and the Queen
on d5 has no check and always needs to
protect f7 the computer actually gives
king of a troop t7 and King g8 back cool
very nice
yeah yeah of course in this position he
ate is hanging and he has no move very
funny yeah thanks for watching pretty
interesting game yeah all right yeah
talk to you soon with new videos